deuxième dossier l'indépendance
politique et la présence syrienne depuis
plusieurs mois les signes d'opposition
se multiplient pour l'instant damas
garde le silence
mais les langues se délient à beyrouth
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
stéphane du bain et pierre dick seul ce
discret portrait d'hafez el-assad
l'ancien président de syrie indique où
nous sommes le bureau du chef militaire
syrien de beyrouth
nous lui demandons l'autorisation de
filmer les soldats syriens au liban
refus catégorique ils sont 35 milles
mais à damas on préfère ne pas les
montrer
pourtant juste devant l'immeuble ils
patrouillent au liban ils sont partout
en civil ou en uniforme
les opposants dénoncent régulièrement la
violence de ces trous il y a 6 ans lina
jeune militante chrétienne distribué des
tracts anti syrien les services secrets
surgissent arrestations et
interrogatoires après dix jours de co2
nous battaient avec un avec une raie des
pointures sur des endroits sensibles de
nos corps il nous enlever les cheveux
longs mettait sur le mur efop une fois
par jour vous avez droit dans leur
entrée à la toilette pas de bain
alors c'était toujours les mêmes
questions pourquoi vous n'avez pas la
cire et c'est toujours la même réponse
je leur disais jules m je laime tant
qu'elle est dans parquet les racines et
pas dans mon pays ce sont les chrétiens
qui ont appelé les syriens à l'aide pour
se battre contre les palestiniens
c'était il ya 25 ans ils sont toujours
là et aujourd'hui même leurs plus
fidèles alliés s'interroge walid
joumblatt a été plusieurs fois ministre
au liban
il était pro syriens comme tous les
samedis en tant que chef druze
ils règlent les conflits dans sa
communauté mais ce samedi là il règle
aussi ses comptes avec les syriens
s'intéresse à tout
dans le domaine judiciaire dans le
bonheur de la vie publique dans les
municipalités
un peu tout ils font tous je ne suis pas
contre la présence militaire pour des
raisons stratégiques syrienne vu que
maintenant la région est au bord
peut-être de la guerre on ne sait pas
quoi mais l'ingérence dans le domaine
privé secteur privé public libanais ça
devient je le répète un supporter malgré
l'opposition pour le gouvernement
libanais l'enjeu est avant tout
stratégique l'equilibre de la région est
précaire il n'est donc pas question de
retrait la présence syrienne est légal
jusqu'à maintenant on a besoin de cette
présence pour aider le liban dont soit
au niveau de la stabilité sécurité à
l'intérieur soit au niveau 2
l'enfant là avec les italiens dans
beyrouth
ce portrait de l'ancien président syrien
mort il ya près d'un ans affiche
toujours son petit lire le lien qui unit
le liban à la syrie est l'oeuvre de dieu
vingt-cinq ans après l'entrée des
troupes syriennes au liban de plus en
plus de libanais conteste cette présence
s'agit-il d'une aide d'un pays ami ou
d'une réelle occupation de leur
territoire c'est la question que tous
les libanais se pose et autre exemple de
cette opposition à la syrie on appris ce
soir que le cardinal sfeir patriarche
maronite ne se rendra pas à damas pour
la prochaine visite du pape une raison
clairement politique pour lui at il
expliqué sa présence pourrait être
interprété comme un soutien à la syrie